hey guys it's Monday I'm just undoing
auntie watching game so yes thanks for
doing that
first up congratulations to player
unknowns battlegrounds it was recently
the most played game on Steam hooray
what was that was drawn Ola I don't have
any strings you are cleaning that up
that's right to hide-and-seek Ultimate
Edition recently surpassed dirt of Terry
to be the most played game on Steam with
over eight hundred and seventy seven
thousand consecutive players dota 2
still holds the all-time record with
over 1 million consecutive players in a
single day keeping the statistics
flowing battlegrounds has sold more than
8 million copies since launch on top of
that a tweet from Nico partners analyst
Daniel armored has indicated that pub G
is the best selling game on any single
platform in 2017 in terms of unit souls
the console version of the game will be
launching first on Xbox one as a console
launch exclusive published by Microsoft
there's still no word on how this will
affect a ps4 edition or what the phrase
console launch exclusive actually means
but as soon as we know you'll know so
make sure you're subscribed the English
version of yakusoku ami is out this week
a remake of the ps2 original game and it
seems like seek is not done yet they've
just announced a bunch more yakuza stuff
first up yak is a kilometer was leaked
last week and was subsequently confirmed
to be arriving later this year on ps4
just like yakuza Kewanee this game is
also a remake this time of the ps2 zo
cruiser 2 according to Komatsu the game
is being made on the Yakuza 6 dragon
engine and will include new scenarios
news stories and playable characters the
voice cast is also being completely
recast and Japanese band sim will be
doing the new theme song
Yakuza Korn me too will launch in Japan
on December 7 and will hopefully make
its way to the west at some time later
sig is not done again Komatsu reports
that a free-to-play mobile and PC game
called Yakuza online will debut in Japan
in 2018 set up to the events of Yakuza 6
the title will follow new protagonist in
Chewbacca saga as he returns to the
streets after 17 years in prison that's
about all we know so far aside from the
fact that the game will feature
microtransactions this one sounds like
it's something worth keeping an eye on
though
finally the team behind the yuccas games
has announced they're working on a Fist
of the North Star inspired game called
hakuto guard gotoku for ps4 mr. minosa
was a manga series that
from 1983 to 1988 that featured a
warrior named Kenshiro in a 1990s
nuclear wasteland
no more details again on this one but
with Tokyo Game Show just around the
corner will hopefully be learning more
on all these titles soon finally the
first is creation Club potentially
better known to you guys as Bethesda's
new paid mod system has arrived
footballer 4 on PC as part of a new
update
first there was horse armor that ran new
tools 50 in the Elder Scrolls for
oblivion and Skyrim Spade mods that you
guys work and how do I put this
delicately not fans of now this creation
club but which is the Thursday's new
attempt at working with top models in
the community to create page mods for
the service the thursda has promised it
won't retrofit existing mods to become
paid and the plan is to put creation
club mods through Bethesda's QA process
to ensure total compatibility with other
mods across the platform because the
marketing VP Pete Hines explained to the
creation Club content is more like mini
DLCs than mods all players will get 100
credits but there's this digital
currency for free to start buying
creation Club content and then you'll be
able to buy more if you want to let us
know in that comment section what you
think of the service that is everything
we've got for you today dude let us know
what you thought of today's stories down
in that comment box and do you remember
that we'll be joining you every day of
the working week so you can come back
here same time to hear more gaming news
stories also dare needs to clear all
this up like yeah I am I never like do
it that's seriously was that worth it
yeah because now we got little snacks I
can walk around where were you like five
minutes ago